hello welcome my name is Alton Hill and
we have worked together on a few
interactive installations and yeah like
was introduced we are the art - oh stop
Billy it's somewhat like our band name
or something yeah I mean search talking
English I'm gonna begin by telling you a
little bit about myself I have a
bachelor's degree in computer science a
PS in CS or a [ __ ] degree in
counter-strike like I like to call it
and I work as a freelance audio and an
art programmer but also to my fair share
of websites and whatnots my second job
is as a musician I compose music and I
also am in a band called seeker which
you should totally check out if you
haven't already and then I also
collaborate with other musicians
currently with all our art nerds on a
new generative robotic piano project
some of my work is most notably the POC
Apollo
it's a generative music piece and it's
written in JavaScript it uses the photos
taking during the moon landings back in
the 60s and 70s as an input to a musical
engine and creates a sort of soundscapes
for the images so you can flick through
the images in a random order and listen
to ambient music that is being generated
in the browser and another project is
the infinite string quartet which is
modular string quartet written by my
brother Wilbur Alto who is a composer
and we created like a interactive
version of it that runs in the browser
and you can
selects modules or clips from the string
quartet and arrange them in a 3d space
around you and create your very own
version you can play for hours and
creating creepy string quartet music
with this and yet then the project I'm
working on with only here we are
contemplating how to make it sound more
like a flower now artists and yeah there
is being released very soon
I am foolish I am a merely a developer I
also have a ph degree but no joke about
it I work for the local contracting
company called Kirk and I'm also going
to use the opportunity to talk about
some of my projects since I have this
platform one recent one I did this is a
weakened Chrome extension whoo so it
basically takes all non-vegan words
meaty words and replace them here we
have bacon and that gets replaced to
Kermit's wife of 40 years then recently
just earlier this month we did me and
Hunter we did another heart pop project
using the facade outside this was done
for the foundation go rat and this
basically a giant heart projected over a
deck where the input is users heart beat
heart rate yeah so let's talk about
paint splatter it's an interactive
installation where you can participate
on your phone and the simplest way to
describe it is that it's a giant shared
digital canvas made out of Harper's huge
led facade and anyone with access to
Internet and a smart device or a
computer can interact with this canvas
by splashing virtual paint on it which
then trips straight down or sideways
depending on wind direction and force
take it away third
so when you're creating interactive art
it's really important that the user
input is simple and rewarding in this
piece we utilize the fact that most
people like vandalizing especially
without many consequences so anonymously
splashing paint on Iceland's most
expensive building seemed like a pretty
rewarding and simple way to be an outlet
for that kind of behavior for the first
few days we had thousands of visits both
from people all over the world and some
people standing out sight and the storm
splashing for hours the reason why it
became so popular is how interactivities
the fact that by pressing a small area
on your phone results in a giant blob
visible to all participants from all
over the world it's the key to making
this all work it's also pretty visibly
pleasing on the props of a well-defined
look and the user input is greatly
limited this way we could avoid making
this look like a giant shared Microsoft
Paint document we could also avoid
mankind's most drawn figure on any
shared platform the phallic symbol and
how we pissed this thing the design
process was very straightforward it just
started with conceptual sketches on
paper like all good ideas start and the
whole concept was then thoroughly
determined before we started coding
anything so that helped us really keep
things in scope and we did one thing
well I believe next step was doing some
web mock-ups just to get our gist of how
the animation would look like and I'm
going to show you a code pan I did here
no this is this is my home this is where
I lived I used to keep this on my screen
yeah here this here's the first like
some how crappy interactive and with
input parameters what would leak yeah
just to get our sense of the rendering
and and main obstacles this took like 30
minutes to do so and and it was so good
to have this with the project proposal
okay back to the presentation the
biggest unknown factor in the whole
project was how to render stuff on the
light facade of harpa but fortunately it
had been done before so it just got
access to some node.js rendering server
code written by Owen Hindley which we
could fork and adapt to our tests and
the networking part was also pretty
straightforward we just used socket IO
and set up a small up on an Heroku
instance that handles all the events to
and from users like you press and make a
plop and it sense the event to all
connected participants and it also
contains some rudimentary game logic and
input sanitizing and even throttling
like you would to so yeah when we said
hola we faced some real-world problems
since the render server had to be
located in the basement with the rest of
the lab controllers that meant we had to
go up and down up and down endlessly in
our feedback loop and this is a video of
one of those times but it was a great
physical exercise good contrast and we
also got the lost few times like there
are thousands of it's half price like
Hogwarts School
it's almost always changing and I think
there are a lot of people like stuck
down there
yeah probably is like a small population
by now yeah and since this was already
online we wanted to allow more people to
participate so we decided to set up a
live stream and with a very limited
budget to be part of the phone and we
kind of duct taped it to the ceiling of
the hotel lobby next across from ARPA
this worked out great we got a lot of
traction on at it but pretty soon people
started complaining about the tourist
bus that was always blocking the view
like every half hour or so and also the
staff at the hotel they weren't that
pleased through this unidentified phone
that at some point was maybe possibly
broadcasting their conversations through
the internet and we also encountered
some problems with deploying the renter
server here in Harper because we had to
connect our computer to six unmarked
Ethernet cables through a selection of
routers and adapters which had to be in
done in correct order for it to work it
was most definitely not a very atomic
deployment process and first almost like
programming the ENIAC or or making punch
card programs so yes we had already we
had also become like our small TV
station yes we had to fulfill our duties
as a 24/7 live TV station
did you already mention the the main
complaint from the reddit users what's
that
so there was a tourist I saw her purse
yeah you're not even listening to me and
then we got spammed it was bound to
happen somebody found a way to
circumvent the rate-limiting Oh No and
why am I even telling you this all
programmers sent and JavaScript
and then we got like properly hacked now
this is actually a very funny story
because somebody found a way to override
our color scheme we had like a very
limited color scheme you could not draw
black for instance so you could not like
clear the screen or or or something like
that but somebody found a way to
override it and was suddenly able to
draw arbitrary buffers of images by just
swatting paint very fast with the for
loop and we knew this was a possibility
from the start but didn't have the
resources to prevent it and except for
some basic rate limiting and
exponentially increasing pack of periods
but this was actually a very fun
challenge and war was upon us Iceland is
very small and the company communities
here are even smaller and the proof for
that is that I just got on messenger and
guessed who the hacker was and this was
not a penny before the hacker started
writing his name on the facade and I was
right
the hacker was my former computer game
programming teacher at the University
and he is also a programmer at CCP and
the only person in Iceland I knew that
would be able to do such a thing and
invest the time to do it properly so we
could immediately recognize his way of
doing the hacking because it was very
professionally done we approached him
and after a few hours of negotiations he
surrendered and told us all about how he
did it and he even sent us all the code
and a lot of comments on our code which
was very hard to read so he was able to
like draw arbitrary buffers with paint
and this is from his coat various like
neatly organized his name in a proper
two-dimensional array
he wrote the whole rendering service
that was running on his computer that's
pumped our server with paint blob events
and enabled him to do this so he was
like rendering on a rendering server on
a rendering server because we all like
rendering servers right but we made it
harder for him we just increased the
race rate limiting a bit and added some
extra throttling and without degrading
the experience of the normal non
spamming user and this fight was ongoing
throughout the duration of the display
he also was able to avoid because the
paint leaks and if you draw something it
won't stay there forever because it gets
the paint leaks and somebody else paints
over it but he added the skewing factor
he could tune to his taste too yet to be
able to create like very straight images
and then we added random noise to it to
decrease the resolution of what this
hacker was able to draw and this is
still in the code you see it if you if
you press the half power if you if you
splat paint you can see that it
dominates enter like yeah it doesn't
come exactly in the center of where you
clicked and also it's totally on concept
because it's plotting paint like with
with some paint plot that's very
unprecedent
if you spend some time in Iceland you
quickly learn that the weather here is
quite unpredictable
and when we did this the first time
which was in 2016 there was basically a
crazy storm throughout the whole time it
was up and that was a great way to show
off the feature that you know we were
using the wind force and wind direction
to to render so we just looked on the
bright side there weren't a lot of
people like outside trying a lot more
people on the Internet
but the year after we set it up again
and the weather was way better
just nice weather and almost no wind at
all which proved problematic because
every time there was absolutely no wind
our renters are requests because we were
somewhere in our calculations we were
tape dividing by a zero and for the
first time this happened me and doctor
we were gonna be on live television and
this happened like five minutes before
that happened and as you can see in this
picture here's the mayor in 2016 lots of
wind you can see his hair it's it's
crazy and 2017 this is like a frozen
under server absolutely no end and me
and alt or somewhere in the back having
a panic attack but we somehow got
through the interview with like
demonstrating how this worked without it
actually working at all and nobody
seemed to notice which is a pretty good
thing yes we learnt a few lessons
through this whole process first being
that we should avoid at any means any
ribbon-cutting ceremonies by politicians
with like huge scissors especially when
it's on live television secondly you
should always allow for the weather even
when you're writing code even if it has
nothing to do with well as we should you
should do it especially here in Iceland
and it's always fun when your work is
worth hacking at least when it's not
done maliciously and yeah while it well
it's entertaining this
Pease revolves around the concept of
vandalism and that everybody gets their
say everybody can participate so
programmers with the programming skills
they can of course participate but if
you intend to do so please behave
yourselves we don't have the money to
fight you so thank you so much for
listening and the piece is accessible at
paint j/s Khan is or just paint dot is
it's been a pleasure talking here and we
would like to know if any of you had any
questions we are happy to answer yeah
the question there yeah
the insights of how many users and how
many user apps at the same time have
used this the night when it went live on
reddit
we got like I think 7,000 hits over a
short period of time and that was after
we set up the live streaming cam so even
if you were abroad you could splat paint
and see a live stream of it actually
happening yeah for some reason that
wasn't like a huge spike at one point it
was like pretty even I don't know why
yeah and the log file from the server
was around 300 megabytes if that tells
you anything any more questions
oh yeah yeah we did one a couple of
weeks ago which we told you about
briefly it saw we connected a heart rate
sensor to heart animation on front of
Harper so you could come up to the
second floor and make it sense your
heartbeat and then rayful's would form
that planted nicely on the light facade
yeah and we allowed for zero but no one
had zero heart rate
sorry no I was I was thinking on the
webcam was taken down because the hotel
manager thought we were spying on some
guests yeah hotel and our friend needed
this phone back as well yeah poor guy
did you want to like follow us we'll
take care of it
just ask away if you have any questions
I think that's what what is it what is
the timeout is like two seconds four
seconds eight seconds what okay
there's a line that silly TCP joke sorry
I'm very sorry thank you so much for
listening
[Applause]